في دراسه حديثه نشرتها صحيفه المدينه
السعوديه توقعت ان يصل حجم الانفاق في
المملكه خلال شهر رمضان القادم الى نسبه
44% مقارنه برمضان الماضي ذكرت الدراسه ان
50% من المستهلكين الذين استشارتهم قالوا
انهم يشترون بناء على العروض الترويجيه
اما الشعب المصري فيستهلك سلعا غذائيه في
رمضان تصل قيمتها الى نحو 120 مليار جنيه
مقارنه ب 60 مليار جنيه في الاشهر العاديه
اي نصف القيمه تقريبا هوسوا التسوق
الرمضاني يرتفع في المغرب كذلك بنسبه تصل
لاكثر من 16% خلافا لباقي اشهر السنه خاصه
على السلع كالزيت والعسل لتحضير الحلويات
ما ينعكس على ميزانيه الاسر ويثقل كاهلها
بمصاريف اضافيه معدل انفاق الاسره
الاردنيه على الطعام والشراب في حدود من
33 الى
34% وذلك بمبلغ يقدر ب
12,519 دينارا سنويا للاسره الواحده
ويتضاعف هذا الانفاق مرتين او ثلاث مرات
في بعض الاحيان في رمضان وياتي على حساب
نفقات اخرى
[موسيقى]